hey what's up guys my name is jonah
welcome to another devlog monday
on a tuesday again i hope you all have
had an amazing week
i have had a uh about a five out of ten
week i don't know
does that sound bad five out of ten
that's like
average but it but it it doesn't sound
very good
no i think i had a six out of ten week
for those of you who don't know this is
basically like a little series on my
channel where i just talk about
what i've done over the last week
specifically relating to the hazel
engine
basically just talking about the new
features and how the actual
implementation of all of that
went now of course i am referring to
hazeldev which is like the patreon
supported version of hazel if you want
to get access to it
then you can help support the
development of hazel and everything here
on my channel by going to patreon.com
the link will be in the description
below
and you will get access to all of this
source code as well as an amazing
community where we kind of help each
other and talk about
game engines and stuff like that now
this week
i mean a lot of things have happened and
actually last week i'll leave the link
to the last devlog up there
i talked about how we are doing some
very exciting things
and i think next week realistically is
when i'm going to start
kind of talking about them this is still
exciting don't get me wrong this video
is exciting
but the kind of stuff that we've been
working on is like
i think next week like you're going to
want to be around for that basically as
you guys know i have been kind of
working towards getting hazel to a point
where i can actually start creating
content with it
specifically i want to be able to build
a game one of my goals for hazel is like
hopefully within a year from now i would
like to build a small game and release
it on steam
like that's just the goal because i want
to prove that hazel is capable of
shipping a game
and i mean who wouldn't want to ship a
game with their own engine that's kind
of the whole point of this game engine
and so i've got a really exciting idea
for a game and this is kind of i guess
what i'm working on really over like the
last few weeks and months i guess
is building the engine to the point
where it can support the idea that i
have
now the actual idea that i have is uh as
small or as large as you want it to be
of course i'm gonna reveal the idea
right now you guys will have to just
wait and kind of see how the game
actually turns out
but what i mean is like it's not it's
not very big in scope but it can be
it can grow you can iterate over it and
you can add as many or as little
features as you want and it should like
the core mechanics will still kind of
stay the same
so in that sense i'm kind of excited to
start working on this now as you know
for a game to be playable
it's kind of like i don't want to just
play it in the editor that would be a
bit weird hey guys why don't you
download the hazel
engine and then like open the editor and
then go file open and then load the game
and play it that's
that's weird so instead we obviously
want some kind of run time we obviously
want to be able to play the game
outside of the editor as like a
standalone product and that is what i
worked on this week
amongst like 50 other things so without
further ado let's take a look at
what this looks like so this is hazelnut
i'm sure a lot of you are familiar with
this this is like the editor
for hazel if i go ahead and just load a
scene we'll go with the sponsor demo
this is just an example that i'm going
to use here so let's talk about the
architecture of this scene a little bit
so
it's pretty simple um we've got the
actual model but then the model itself
is also like
hooked up with nvidia physx as an actual
um
like as an actual mesh collider it's
very very far from optimal for physics
use
just just so that we're clear we're
actually working on ways now to
be able to um yeah specify essentially
what we want to use as like physics sub
measures versus like rendering
submeasures
i'll have more videos on that later but
basically if i click to select added
this little wireframe
view just so we could see for now you
know what's selected that will of course
change
but you can see that like a lot of these
things are very very dense which isn't
very good for physics i mean there
should just be a box collider
around this um you know this little
plant here but instead there's like a
bunch of triangles and all that stuff
but anyway
point is there's a physics collider on
this if we look at sponsor itself you
can see we have a mesh collider and a
rigid body
the point of that is just to make it
walkable so if i look at player
we've got parented entities by the way i
don't think i've talked about that uh
thanks to peter
and a few other people on the team as
well we've got parented uh
entities now which is great so we can
parent the camera to the player which is
nice
but you can see that over here uh for
example um
you know we have a rigid body a dynamic
rigid body and a capture collider now
the player
is actually located i think if i hit f
to kind of focus
ish um then i can uh see the player it's
actually actually here
right if i show a gizmo you'll be able
to see where he is i
i got rid of the mesh component the
actual mesh component on this so there's
a mesh component that will render
something
this is not actually being rendered
anymore uh it just kind of appears here
but one thing i did add was
physics colliders so if i turn that on
you can actually see what the physics
collider looks like
in a very kind of nvidia physxy green
um i'm sure that's not actually the
nvidia physics green but it's green and
that's the point
um so that that kind of capsule collider
is what collides with the mesh collider
of the actual um
sponsor model and that's how we can kind
of walk around and then we have a
have a c-sharp script called fps player
which
uh is basically what controls the camera
and what kind of
all the behavior that you see the wasd
keys the the mouse
um that's all kind of scripted in there
and by the way if you guys are watching
and you are patrons and you do have
access to hazeldev
go ahead and try and run this right like
that's the whole point this is on this
is on the master branch right now
you can just clone that basically follow
the setup instructions
um you know build it in release
preferably so this is fast
and then uh if you go into asset scenes
and spawns a demo that's what i dragged
in here so definitely try this out and
let me know how it goes for you guys
um we don't really i don't have any amd
graphics cards to test
on so at the moment it's a little bit um
crashy i think not very happy um in
general with amd cards like hazel i mean
so i definitely need to get an amd card
uh into the office as soon as possible i
think so i can start testing on that
but basically um other than that it
should be fine and you can actually
run it in the runtime which i'm about to
show you as well so anyway so we have
that script um so if i
hit play you know i'll be dropped into
this world i can kind of move around you
know i can jump i can interact with the
world whatever
um that's all kind of here um and it's
all kind of in a runtime state it's been
like that for a while you know i can
do whatever i want it captures the mouse
oh that's good but obviously we can only
run it inside the editor so how do we
run it outside the editor well first of
all let's
just like modify the scene quickly i
don't know let's just make it slightly
different
maybe i'll add like a taurus um we'll
get rid of the mesh collider on that
because we don't need it
um make it a little bit big put it into
the center of the world
just kind of for fun i guess so you can
see this is like a dynamically modified
uh scene let me just not maybe show the
selection
so we can see what it looks like all
right beautiful we've got a nice little
torus here
so ctrl s to save the scene and then i'm
just going to close
like hazelnut right so we're going to
close it um
that took a while and then hazel runtime
i'm going to set that as a startup
project and it's just set to load that
kind of sponsor scene
so if i hit f5 and run that then you can
see that i'm dropped into the world and
we're actually full screen here
which is pretty cool there's no title
bar nothing like that
there's our taurus that we just added
right it's all completely kind of
um i guess uh running in like a runtime
fashion with no editor
nothing whatsoever and then all i had to
really do was just launch the
application and this is what we're
created with so this is kind of i guess
you know the beginnings of what will
become
you know the hazel run time i do want to
mention a few things like first of all
this isn't really like the hazel run
time right i know i said it was and it
is in a sense
but what i mean is like this is just
loading the source assets
this is still loading like the fbx model
of like i think it might actually even
be an obj which is a disaster
um of the sponsor scene and like you
know maybe the taurus fbx or whatever
it's still loading all of that the scene
files are still like written in yaml
and they're still loading all that text
right this is not packaged it's not like
it's not built to be like a runtime kind
of binary format just yet this is still
all the raw source assets
now to someone actually playing this
though so like for the purposes of like
play testing not exactly like
distribution
it's the same thing right also i'm not
sure if
it might seem a little bit laggy in the
screen capture i'm not 100 sure it's
definitely
like running it vsync here but um maybe
because it's like
actually full screen and not like a
borderless windowed um
it might be i might not be using game
capture for that but anyway the point is
that um
you know for someone who's play testing
this this gets the job down that's kind
of the whole point of this right we want
to be able to actually
build a game in this and then like play
it full screen as if you were playing a
game
um and that's obviously what this uh
achieves now in
in the future though of course we would
want to you know
basically author i guess or like build
our assets
into like a hazel like hazel model
format and all that stuff hazel texture
stuff like that
that are basically ready to go in a good
kind of gpu
friendly way so that we can just load
that or memory map the files and load
them in you know maybe we want all the
assets in like a binary blob with like a
virtual file system and like compression
and
there's so much kind of you know runtime
distribution stuff that we
need and we will obviously get to that
stage but this is kind of just
the beginning you know being able to um
being able to run uh like that it takes
a while to
to switch from full screen to not full
screen on the video capture but
in real life it's it's completely
different anyway hope you guys enjoyed
that little look at the hazel run time
as i mentioned
if you are a patron then just go ahead
and like try it out for yourselves
because all of this is pushed it's ready
to go
you can try it out on your computer and
you can look through the code obviously
um huge thank you as always to everyone
who does help support the hazel project
i think it's really cool uh i always say
this but it is really cool like
you know what we're able to achieve here
and as i mentioned like
as we start actually using hazel to
create stuff um i think it's gonna be
amazing i'm definitely going to
start making some more videos i think
that are actually going to be about like
content creation
and uh and stuff like that and my
journey i guess with that so it's going
to be really cool i think when we get to
that stage anyway huge thank you to
everyone don't forget to like the video
if you enjoyed
and i will see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you